RoboCop Rogue City feels like a game
trying too hard to emulate the
experience of its Inspirations having
played a few hours of the game at a
preview event I'm a bit conflicted
regarding how I feel about the upcoming
sci-fi first person shooter Rogue City
captures the look and sounds and overall
feel of the first two RoboCop movies
exceptionally well but by sticking so
close to the general Vibe of those
movies it creates several moments that
aren't very fun to play it has good
voice acting and some intriguing RPG
inspired elements working in its favor
though
[Music]
in Rogue City who plays old Detroit cop
Alex Murphy who after being fatally
wounded is rebuilt as a cyborg called
RoboCop armed with enhanced strength and
durability Advanced scanning technology
and other Cutting Edge tools you're
tasked with bringing lethal Justice to
the growing criminal element of the city
after a hostage situation leaves you
partially damaged however you begin to
remember your old life and the wife you
once had causing you to accidentally
hesitate in a dangerous situation with
your High Reps wary of your mental state
and the general public unsure if you can
be trusted you have to figure out how to
proceed forward case to case to earn
that Faith back all the while shaping
the future of old Detroit you can punish
every crime with aggressive Force for
example or take the time to resolve
things more amicably this game emulates
the visuals sounds and just the general
Vibe of the original RoboCop and its
1990 sequel the two best entries in the
franchise very well much like alien
isolation or Star Wars Jedi fall in
order Rogue City feels genuine to the
storyline of its respective franchise
recapturing the aesthetic and then
squeezing a brand new story into a
familiar narrative framework Rogue City
obviously differs from games like alien
isolation or Fallen order by not
tackling its World from the perspective
of a never-before-seen main character
this does mean at least the first glance
from the few hours I played Rogue City
sometimes feels a little too close to
the original RoboCop movies those movies
already explore themes of control and
Free Will through the lens of Alex
Murphy leaving Rogue City feeling like
it's retreading old ground it's too soon
to make a definitive call on the full
storyline but I am worried that the
efforts to keep Rogue City faithful to
the vision of the original movies may
result in the story ultimately feeling
been there done that at the very least I
was able to see how Rogue City's
faithfulness to the RoboCop movies
action resulted in what appears to be
boring uninspired combat RoboCop is
regularly depicted as a juggernaut of
Destruction in the movies tanking
bullets and dispatching criminals with a
slow but lethal Precision of a machine
Rogue city gives you a similar degree of
power which means you never feel like
your life is in any danger I played
through whole levels where after a fight
erupted I just stood in place out in the
open and slowly turned to kill everyone
around me one bullet at a time the
health I lost from the experience was
trivial and given the prevalence of
healing items it seemed like I couldn't
go more than three rooms without
stumbling on a small cash to refill my
inventory it left firefight's feeling
too easy a room of gunman isn't an
engaging challenge in this case it's
merely an annoying speed bump slowing
down the momentum of the game's story
all that said I was playing the game at
its normal difficulty it's possible the
game presents a more engaging Challenge
on hard it certainly doesn't help that
the shooting mechanics don't feel all
that good presumably in an effort to
match the slower and mechanical nature
of Robocop you also can't adjust your
aim all that quickly and The Recoil of
automatic Firearms makes it tricky to
land headshots which are the best part
of combat because pulling off such a
feat rewards you with a wonderful
explosion of blood and gore that
splatters against the environment with a
satisfying slap
the expansive skill trees at least hint
at ways of improving your ability to
land shots with presumably late game
abilities like ricocheting bullets off
walls to strike enemies from behind but
I didn't see these in practice during
the preview so I don't know how much
they actually help and even if they do
your skill points feel better suited
elsewhere Rogue City features side
quests interrogations and other RPG
inspired Choice driven moments and
spending points to increase your skills
used in these areas gives you more fun
options I like that unlocking the
ability to inherently know which
responses and dialogue best appeal to
the common good gave me some direction
during conversations and that unlocking
more efficient scanning technology made
it easier to find the necessary evidence
to proceed on certain cases there just
seems to be more nuance and Challenge on
the RPG side of the game where RoboCop
can fail certain interactions not end up
with an ideal outcome and have to find
an alternative solution to the problem
at hand I'm curious as to how this side
of the game might expand and evolve
further into the story whereas the gun
Play Feels lacking it seems like there's
potential for the RPG inspired elements
to Impact gameplay and narrative in
interesting ways the story of Rogue City
seems to be a good time even in its
familiarity seeing RoboCop fight against
drug dealers with lethal Force struggle
with his Humanity in Remembering his
past and Aid a crime-stricken city is
hardly new for the franchise as we've
already said and the eerily stiff facial
models make for some strange
conversations but the voice acting is
good leaning into that 80s action movie
camp that made the first movie so
beloved by fans familiar characters
sound and act as you expect them to
while a handful of new faces hint that
this game could maybe go in compelling
directions that we haven't seen in
Robocop store before whether it's enough
to carry the game through its seemingly
lackluster combat remains to be seen all
in all Rogue City sits in a weird place
for me I love the way it looks and
sounds capturing the vibe of the
original movies I'm less impressed with
the game play however notably how
immaterial the combat feels or the
protagonist is so strong there's never
any enjoyable challenge to it I do think
the RPG inspired side of the game has
some promise especially if those
elements are used to tell a fresh story
for the RoboCop Mythos but until we get
our hands on the full game we'll just
have to wait and see RoboCop Rogue city
is scheduled to launch for Xbox series
XS PS5 and PC in September 2023 and to
keep updated on this game and other
first-person shooters be sure to
subscribe to GameSpot
don't worry partner we'll stay in
contact